>> Neil: WHO KNEW THE STORM OVER
STORMY AS IN STORMY DANIELS AND
THE PAYMENT TO HER, TURNS OUT
THE PRESIDENT DID REMEMBER THIS
MATTER AFTER LONG INSISTING HE
KNEW NOTHING ABOUT THIS MATTER.
I HAD HEARD THIS BEFORE A LOT
AND ADDRESSED IT LAST NIGHT.
LET ME BE CLEAR, MR. PRESIDENT,
HOW CAN YOU DRAIN THE SWAMP IN
YOU'RE THE ONE THAT KEEPS
MUDDYING THE WATER.
YOU DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THAT
$130,000 PAYMENT TO A PORN STAR
UNTIL YOU DID.
SAID YOU KNEW NOTHING ABOUT HOW
YOUR FORMER LAWYER MICHAEL COHEN
HANDLED THIS UNTIL ACKNOWLEDGE
HANDLED THIS UNTIL ACKNOWLEDIN
HANDLED THIS UNTIL ACKNOWLEDING
TODAY YOU WERE BEHIND THE
RETAINER PAYMENT THAT TOOK CARE
OF THIS.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE A LIAR.
I'M HAVING A DEVIL OF A TIME
FIGURING OUT WHICH NEWS IS FAKE.
YOUR OWN WORDS GIVE ME LOTS OF
PAUSE.
I GUESS YOU'RE TOO BUSY DRAINING
THE SWAMP TO EVER STOP AND SMELL
THE STINK YOU'RE CREATING.
THAT'S YOUR STINK.
MR. PRESIDENT, THAT'S YOUR
SWAMP.
PRETTY CLEAR, BUT A LOT OF YOU
CLEARLY TICKED OFF.
FRANK ON FACEBOOK WRITES "NEIL,
YOU PROVED TODAY THAT YOU'RE A
LEFTIST LIBERAL AND A MORON.
I WILL NO LONGER LISTEN TO YOUR
SHOW.
CIAO."
BOBBY WRITES "YOU JUST LOST
MILLIONS OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS
TODAY WITH YOUR RANT ON YOUR
PRESIDENT.
ENJOY YOUR LOW RATINGS."
GLENDA ON FACEBOOK "WE ALL KNOW
TRUMP ISN'T PERFECT, BUT MANWAY
TO PILE ON.
MAYBE WE SHOULD GO BACK AND
EXAMINE EVERY WORD OUT OF YOUR
MOUTH."
WHICH IT IS?
JOEY RIGHTS, "CAVUTO, SHUT THE
HELL UP.
YOU'RE AN IDIOT" AM NOT.
"REALLY CAVUTO, YOU SUCK."
LINDA
LIND
LINDA WRITES "I WAS ASTOUNDED,
CAVUTO HAS BECOME A TRUE JERK.
TODAY IS THE LAST TIME I WILL
USE MY ELECTRICITY TO WATCH YOUR
FAT FACE."
LIKE I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT ONE
BEFORE.
LINDA WRITES "TOTALLY AGREE.
MANY CANNOT SEE PAST THEIR BLIND
DEVOTION."
TIM ON FACEBOOK WRITES "YOUR
COMMENTARY TODAY NAILED IT AND
I'M A REPUBLICAN."
SCOTT WRITES "BOYCOTT FOX NEWS
UNTIL NEIL CAVUTO IS
TERMINATED."
JULIE, "SHUT UP, NEIL."
NO, YOU SHUT UP.
GREG, "CAVUTO IS LIKE THE RHINO
ESTABLISHMENT.
ALWAYS HAS BEEN."
HOW DARE YOU CALL ME FAT, KAREN.
ANYWAY, DIDN'T YOU KNOW THE
CAMERA ADDS 20 POUNDS?
ASK ANY RHINO.
IF A RHINO COULD TALK.
BY THE WAY, IT'S NOT LIKE THE
ANIMAL.
IT'S RINO.
FAT CHANCE YOU KNEW THAT ONE.
SEE HOW I BLENDED THAT.
VANESSA "I FELT SO BAD FOR YOU
WHEN YOU RETURNED FROM OPEN
HEART SURGERY."
I FEEL EVEN WORSE YOU SURVIVED.
DID YOU WRITE THAT?
KEN "IF YOU THINK YOU CAN FALL
BACK ON YOUR MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
AND OTHER MEDICAL ISSUES, THINK
AGAIN YOU CHUBBY CHUMP."
PEACE.
KEN, I'M PUTTING YOU DOWN AS A
MAYBE ON ME, BUT I THINK I COULD
WIN YOU OVER.
THIS ONE FROM IOWA "ALL THIS
HATE BECAUSE YOU'VE NEVER GOTTEN
AN INTERVIEW WITH DONALD TRUMP.
WOW, WHAT A VINDICTIVE,
HATEFUL," CANNOT SAY THAT WORD.
I'VE HAD PLENTY OF INTERVIEWS
WITH DONALD TRUMP OVER THE
YEARS, PROBABLY DOZENS.
I'VE JUST NOT ASKED FOR OR SHOWN
INTEREST IN A CHAT WITH HIM AS
PRESIDENT NOW.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN I STILL DON'T
COVER HIM.
I'M JUST NOT INTERESTED IN
JOINING THE CONGA LINE OF FOLKS
EAGER TO INTERVIEW HIM.
THEY ALL DO A GREAT JOB.
THERE IS LITTLE I COULD ADD.
IT'S NOT REALLY PERSONAL, IT'S
JUST BUSINESS.
CLYDE IN ATLANTA, "WOULD IT HAVE
KILLED YOU JUST ONCE TO MENTION
THE AMAZING MARKET RUN-UP UNDER
HIS WATCH."
I DID.
I THINK A LOT MORE THAN JUST
ONCE.
THIS MARKET'S THE BOMB.
WE ARE IN A STOCK BOMB CYCLONE.
SOME HAVE A FEELING THERE'S GOT
TO BE A SLOWDOWN HERE.
WE DON'T SEE IT.
A LOT OF THE RUN WE'VE SEEN IS
MORE POSITIVE ENVIRONMENT.
ANOTHER MILESTONE ON THE DOW
TODAY.
25,000 NOW FOR THE MARKETS.
IT'S BEEN A HISTORIC RUN.
A LOT OF THESE GUYS MIGHT NOT BE
BIG PERSONAL FANS OF DONALD
TRUMP, BUT THEY SURE AS HECK ARE
BIG FANS OF WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS
COOKING UP.
BIG TAX CUTS.
MY POINT WITH SHOWING OFF OF
THAT IS TO STRESS COVERING THIS
PRESIDENT, ANY PRESIDENT, ANY
ISSUE.
JUST BECAUSE I'M NOT ALWAYS
PRAISING DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T
MEAN I'M NEVER TRUMP ERROR
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
KIM THINGS OTHERWISE.
"YOU'RE THE FAKE NEWS NEVER
TRUMPER THAT THE PRESIDENT LIKES
TO WARN US ALL ABOUT, AND YOU'RE
FAT, TOO."
OKAY.
I MOVE ON.
FAKE NEWS WORKS BOTH WAYS,
KIMMY.
EVERY FACULTY PRESENTED LAST
NIGHT WAS REAL.
EVERY COMMENT I USED FROM THE
PRESIDENT WAS HIS, NOT MY WORDS.
HIS WORDS.
WORD FOR WORD.
NOT MY TWEET.
HIS TWEET.
NOTHING WAS FAKE.
EVERYTHING I SHARED WAS REAL.
NO MATTER, BILLY BOB E-MAILS
"YOU'RE A SMOKE POMPOUS WIND
BAG, I HOPE YOU CROAK ON THAT
PORK CHOP TONIGHT."
WAIT A MINUTE.
HOW DID YOU KNOW I'M HAVING PORK
CHOPS TONIGHT!
"THIS ONE I'M DRAWN TO YOU FOR
SOME REASON.
LAST NIGHT MIGHT HAVE PROVED BY.
GOOD JOB BEEF CAKES."
BY THE WAY, IS THAT YOU?
SHEILA "THIS IS WHAT'S CALLED
FAIR AND BALANCED."
ANGELA TWEETS, "I'LL START
WATCHING YOU, NEIL.
KEEP REPORTING THE TRUTH."
BOB WRITES, "I HATE TO SAY IT,
BUT YOU ARE SPOT-ON.
HAVING A GREAT AGENDA AND
RESULTS ARE NEGATED BY A
CHILDISH BEHAVIOR."
I'M NOT HERE TO PROVIDE LESSONS
JUST FACTS.
WORDS MATTER, YES TWEETS MATTER.
I WON'T LECTURE YOU ABOUT LEET
I WON'T LECTURE YOU ABOUT LEE
I WON'T LECTURE YOU ABOUT EAE
I WON'T LECTURE YOU ABOUT EATI
I WON'T LECTURE YOU ABOUT EATING
A SALAD.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE CAREFUL
CALLING ANYONE ELSE BEING FAKE.
I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT REAL.
I HOPE YOU HAVE A REAL GOOD
WEEKEND AND THINK TWICE ABOUT